you were watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video so
last week I took to Twitter to ask
people what they wanted to see in terms
of shorter format videos one of the
topics that came up was Apple's first
sales decline since 2003 so why are
Apple sales falling in this video we'll
find out last month Apple reported its
first year-over-year drop in iPhone
sales in its history
Apple Inc has posted its first ever
decline in iPhone sales and first a
revenue drop in more than a decade as
the company credited with inventing the
smart phone struggles with an
increasingly saturated markets a 16
percent drop when compared to the first
quarter of 2015 and a 32 percent drop
when compared to the last quarter of
2015
here's a chart breakdown of Apple's
total revenue structure iPhones are so
crucial to Apple's business that this
drop cost them 13% of their entire
revenue despite all of this Apple's
still managed to sell 51 million phones
this quarter second only to Samsung's 81
million before we get into the reasons
for the decline I wanted to get a feel
of what people thought about Apple
currently so I went out and asked a few
of my friends the average answer went
something like this Apple just isn't
innovating like they used to and Tim
Cook just isn't the same breed as Steve
Jobs I totally agree with all of this
and I would add that the smart phone
competition from Android is stronger
than it's ever been
so for Apple to sit still is a little
risky at the moment doesn't look like
there is anything that would drive
significant growth for Apple from here
as they've been behaving now you know if
they came out with a breakthrough
product or price then you might see a
change particularly if it's different
than the other smartphone makers in this
market but absent that kind of
innovation in in price or features I
think we're in a much more gradual and
uncertain
that being said one of my friends did
say something very interesting
this friend told me that he thought
Apple wasn't stupid enough to let the
world just pass them by and that they
were secretly syncing millions of
dollars of R&D to surprise the soil with
a revolutionary product in the next two
to five years and as it turns out he is
not alone of those views
Dustin seemed like it's going to come in
iPads which are in a serious decline it
doesn't seem like it's going to come in
max which also declined so if you want
the kind of growth that Apple investors
are used to they're going to need
something else we've been talking about
a TV for years that seems like it was
kicked to the backburner possibly a car
there's another really interesting
moment on the earnings call where one of
the analysts asked about virtual reality
and Tim Cook is of course isn't going to
reveal anything but he kind of hinted
that yeah this is pretty important so
maybe DR is where they're going to go
and maybe they will use a chunk of that
money to push ahead of it their
competitors as interesting as this
theory maybe it still doesn't help the
fact that Apple styles have fallen so
why is this happening the major reasons
are as follows number one underlying
global deflation I'll try my best to
explain this one deflation is an
economic term that basically means the
reduction of money supply usually
resulting in falling prices deflation is
natural and isn't inherently bad but
according to some economists like Peter
chefs Jim Rickards
David Stockman and Mike Maloney who I
recently just had a chat with by the way
according to these economists central
banks have tried to fight deflation
since the 2008 crash by providing
trillions of dollars worth of cheap
low-interest credit instead of this
credit going to productive use it's
actually been allocated wrongly or put
towards bad investments that don't help
the real economy
this causes market distortions that are
only just now starting to reverse and
economies are just left with too much
private household and corporate debt the
end of a worldwide era in which central
bank's printed money injected liquidity
supported markets manipulated and
intruded in the pricing of financial
assets like never before and what it did
was create a massive credit expansion in
the world that's stopping we had 40
trillion of debt in the world in 1995 we
have 225 trillion today everywhere is at
peak debt just as so much debt
saturation it all has to stop being paid
off because of this there's less
spending overall in the economy and a
deflationary cycle begins so what is
this deflationary cycle there's less
spending throughout the economy which
means job cuts the people who lose their
jobs are going to spend less and this
eventually means less profits for the
companies that rely on consumer spending
which means even more job cuts and it
continues this is a macroeconomic force
and affects all companies not just Apple
just take a look at Intel laying off
12,000 jobs and other companies like HP
IBM and Macy's this is all out of apples
control but is probably the biggest
reason for the decrease in sales in my
opinion the second reason for the fall
of Apple sales is market saturation of
the smartphone segment in Western
markets about 60 to 80 percent of those
who want a smartphone have one and even
China a once large engine of iPhone
growth is seeing market saturation and
slow down overall it's already at a
point where a one or two year old
smartphone is good enough for someone
who just wants to shoot some casual
pictures use social media text and chat
the only real place is remaining for
smartphone market growth are the
emerging markets but this is where
Android is king at the moment Google is
working hard to provide capable
smartphones at an affordable price with
efforts like Android one yes there is
the cheaper $400 iPhone se but this is
still expensive compared to some Android
equivalent in addition to this the $400
iPhone se isn't as it seems this leads
on to the third reason the third reason
is a high exchange rate of the u.s.
dollar versus all major currencies for
example here in Australia just a few
years ago the US dollar and the
Australian dollar are about the same but
and for US dollar is 1.3 six times more
expensive a higher US dollar makes
everything that's exported from the
United States more expensive and less
attractive to overseas buyers again this
is another external force for Apple
so iPhones are going to be more
expensive everywhere except for the
United States so that's it
those are my three top exact reasons why
Apple sales are slowing I guess you
could call it four if you add that lack
of innovation so to recap the main
reasons are a lack of innovation
macroeconomic conditions market
saturation and a high exchange rate all
in all it's certainly not the end of the
world for Apple after all they still
make more money selling physical
products than any company on earth this
may just be a temporary blip Apple and
the iPhone 7 may have impressive sales
again but the global economic headwinds
are going to be strong for Apple and all
companies for that matter what do you
guys think do you think Apple's reign is
over or do you think they still have a
lot of life left in them let me know in
the comments section below I also just
want to thank everyone that's supporting
me on patreon if you want to help
support I'll leave a link in the
description no pressure if you don't
want to you don't have to all right
thanks guys give a thumbs up if you
liked this video and subscribe if you're
new to this channel I'll see you again
soon for the next video cheers guys have
a good one
cold fusion it's rethinking
you